has a front-runner emerged in the hunt
for TV's next Bachelor
my name is Colton a source tells ET
production is choosing between Becca's
three runners-up Colton Jason and Blake
and the official announcement will
happen on Tuesday morning if the timing
is right in my life and ABC is ready for
it it would be something that you know I
would consider the front-runner of the
three appears to be Colton a 26-year old
former pro football player he'd be the
show's first virgin bachelor which host
Chris Harrison told us would make for a
quote fascinating story
I am the virgin and Chris dropped
another clue it could be Colton telling
us his status as the bachelor would
depend on what happens in Paradise and
based on this sneak peak it looks like
Colton is leaving Mexico single and not
with TIA
Colton's closest competition is likely
fan favorite Jason I would be willing to
do it the 29 year old New York
investment banker is actually bachelor
at Becca's vote for bachelor I got to
know Jason better than the other guys as
for Becca's first runner-up Blake our
source says he's the least likely
candidate only twice in franchise
history has the bachelorettes first
runner-up going on to hand out roses on
the following season of The Bachelor
alone now if you're an avid watcher of
bachelor nation like I am you may have
heard the rumor that the show was going
to invite Ben Higgins to be the bachelor
again but Chris Harrison told us he was
never offered to come back at least not
yet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]